Pastor I'm a member of The Remnant
church and I have sinned against the
light do you think I should be
re-baptized that's something you should
discuss with your pastor every time you
make a mistake you don't have to be
re-baptized even though sometimes you
know better
but sometimes when the church has been
reproached and the Lord has been
slandered it is necessary to do so if
you could become a drunkard or an
adulterer perhaps you should be but
otherwise perhaps you shouldn't be talk
to your pastor
Pastor what is the difference between a
white witch and a black witch I know
that both are serving the devil but most
people don't believe this what does the
Bible say on the subject we've read
several texts one of them God said you
shouldn't suffer a witch to live
they meet with his disapproval in the
Book of Revelation the Bible says
Sorcerers will not enter the kingdom of
heaven now to know the difference
between black ones and white ones I
thought that was ethnic I don't know of
any other thing and I'm very sincere
someone giving us a text let no man
therefore judge you and meet or drink or
in respect of a holy day on the new moon
and so forth Colossians 2 16. well bless
your heart that's one of my favorite
texts I not only have preached on it I
nailed all those things to the cross
over there you need to study that cross
just go over there and study that cross
and see what Jesus nailed to the cross
in The Book of Leviticus chapter 23
there are several sabbaths
several sabbaths that came once a year
they were strictly Jewish God's Sabbath
goes back to Adam and Eve I really don't
know how to be clearer than that the
ones that pertain to the Jews were
Shadows or symbols of things to come and
the Bible says that you are not to be
judged by any of those which were a
shadow or a type or a symbol or a
representation
of things that will be fulfilled by the
life of Jesus Christ like Passover that
was a Jewish sabbath it still is amongst
the Orthodox Jews Christians don't have
to observe Passover they don't have to
observe Pentecost they don't have to
observe the day of atonement all of
those things were Shadows pointing to
Christ he fulfilled them nailed them to
the Cross but the moral law of God
was not a shadow
these Shadows came because of sin God's
law existed in the Garden of Eden before
sin and Adam and Eve kept the Sabbath
before they ate of the forbidden fruit
so study that and think next place
Pastor from someone who's been with us
I'm in my second marriage and I want to
know if I'm living in adultery because
my first husband is still alive and my
second husband's wife is still alive we
are Christians we have children by our
other marriages I don't want to live in
adultery has God forgiven and blessed us
dear one God forgives you by your faith
not mine and secondly a question of this
personal nature ought to be dealt with
by your pastor in private counsel now
when a person does wrong even including
adultery and then comes the Christ he
accepts you where he finds you would you
say Amen always remember the story of
the woman at the well
Jesus asked her where her husband was
she said she didn't have one he said
you've answered correctly you've had
five and the one you with now isn't
yours but he accepted her right there
now once you become a Christian and you
join the church then you do that it's
quite different you might be subject to
discipline by the church next please
Dr Brooks in repenting should one go to
that person he or she has wronged or
should they just pray to God for
forgiveness the Bible says confess your
faults one to another now you have sins
you confess those to God don't go
telling folks things they don't already
know but if you have mistreated someone
you ought to get it right that's a part
of repentance would you say if you've
stolen five dollars from someone give
them that five dollars back amen make it
right
now I remember once a long time ago I
preached a sermon on confession
and a lady came to me and said I have
been unfaithful to my husband it
happened 10 or 12 years ago but I feel I
should confess I said no you don't
you're gonna have a mess
now if he knew about it then go tell him
and get it right between you but that
was a secret sin between you and God
confess your sins to God your false one
to another I like Christianity because
it's wise next week Pastor do we tithe
from the gross of that income or what we
bring home generally people died from
their increases the word the Bible uses
and that seems to suggest your Prophet
but then there are some who think they
shouldn't tithe on the money that they
take out for IRS
well if you're going to pay all your
debts and then see what you have left
you will not be a faithful timepayer the
Bible says give the Lord the first
fruits of your increase now if you're in
business of course and you have
inventory that is deducted and you pay
tithe on the increase now I'm using a
word incorrectly I say pay time you
don't pay anything you return Ty would
you say Amen it already Belongs to the
Lord now some of us in our personal
lives practice tithing the gross you
can't beat god-giving next please Pastor
Brook someone wants to know when you
pray for yourself and your family that
you may live forever will God answer and
can you see the words take them one at a
time Pastor all right you pray for
yourself that you'll live forever will
God answer that all depends you got to
do more than pray you got to get up off
of your knees and start obeying would
you say amen and if you're living in sin
you got to quit
Freya only works when your life is
conforming to the will of God now if you
do that you may receive eternal life by
faith and you may be assured of it now
next please the second part of the
question can you see the mark of the
beast if you or your friend or even
someone you know gets it no you can't
see it I talked about that last night
some people expect and you hear this now
that they're talking about the mark of
the beast you hear that it's a computer
and everybody's going to have a tattoo
of that's foolishness the Bible doesn't
say that
the Bible says you get it in your
forehead or in your hand meaning you get
it because you believe error or because
you observe error for the sake of
convenience or whatever in the forehead
if you believe in the hand if it's just
to keep your job
but don't expect anything written up
here
and the Seal of God is received in the
forehead but don't expect anything
written up here it means that here is
the seat of the mind and in your mind
you believe
God and you believe his word and you're
committed in your mind one inspired
writer said that receiving the seal is
simply the settling into truth next
please Pastor when you feel you're ready
to go to heaven and you prepare yourself
and then you mess up so many times that
it gets hard to straighten up can you
still be sure you will be saved
now listen folks
sin
Sinners are not going to heaven unless
they overcome sin
amen
that does not mean that you might make
or you might not make a mistake
but a mistake is different than a
deliberate sin sinning against knowledge
going ahead headstrong and head long to
do your own thing in spite of God's
clear work those are two different
things
now you're going to stumble and you're
going to make a mistake now and then and
you're going to always see room for
improvement
but don't think you can get yourself
right with God and then go do your own
will for a month or two and then
everything's all right no no no no you
keep that up you'll drive the Holy Ghost
away
you've got to overcome sin and you do
that by repentance confession belief and
then prayer you can't pray and sin at
the same time and you're not going to be
strong without prayer and dependence
upon God
and you've got to deny yourself Jesus
said you can't do everything you want to
do they've always been things I wanted
to do but character means you say no to
yourself
everybody who commits adultery has an
excuse well I couldn't help it
you better
I don't care how pretty she is
you've got to have character
you got to put God ahead of that
otherwise you'll always be like a reed
in a windstorm whichever way the wind
blows you be in people like that bring
no glory to God and no honor to
themselves or to his church next please
the second part of this question why
doesn't God answer your prayers even
though you know it's for something that
he would want you don't know that a
Christian prays submissive life Jesus
the son of God In The Garden of
Gethsemane asked his father to let the
cup of suffering fast but immediately he
said nevertheless not my will but thine
be done a Christian is not better or
greater than his Lord and Christians
pray that kind of prayer there are a lot
of things that are not wrong they just
might not be best
or wise and so when we pray we pray in
the Name of Christ and we pray according
to God's will the prayer of faith and
this does not mean we're just taking a
chance on prayer oh no when you learn to
have a prayer life you know there are
times God comes right through and there
are other times he waits and you'd learn
to trust him when he does that because
you know he loves you and he's doing
what's best for you but don't ever say
you know that it's best for God you
don't know that you don't know how the
infinite Mind Of God works your mind is
finite next please Pastor Brooks is
there anything wrong with wearing modest
small jewelry how about wedding bands
and engagement rings do you really want
me to fix it for you
I read to you clearly from the word of
God now what do you want me to do fix it
I can't fix it
I wouldn't fix it if it were my mother
standing here asking me this
you can't
dilly dally with God
it's like saying is it all right to take
a little bit of arsenic if I don't take
a whole spoonful
and God doesn't have to deal with us
on that level
we sometimes act like we can bargain
with him well what do you bring to the
bargain except the law so God has his
will it's not his fault that people have
listened to error all of their lives and
have allowed themselves to become
accustomed to that which is unnatural
and forbidden now God says take it off
a Christian always does What God Says
next please
evangelist Brooks I'm convinced that
Saturday is the Sabbath of the Lord but
I've been keeping Sunday so long can I
keep both days
well the first place how can you keep it
when it's not holy to start with
Sunday's the first day of the week it's
a work day and if you want to play golf
as your business if you go fishing
that's your business but it's not holy
God didn't tell you to make a day holy
he already did that he told you to keep
the one holy that he already made holy
and in Acts 5 acts 5 and verse 29 Peter
said we ought to obey God rather than
man he didn't say we ought to obey God
in man we ought to obey God rather
instead of man we ought to obey God
rather than man acts 5 and verse 29. now
what you need to understand is that
Sunday keeping is an offense to God
you need to understand that now I'm not
talking about people who don't know I'm
talking about those to whom truth has
come Sunday keeping is an offense to God
you want me to prove it Matthew 59 in
vain do they worship me teaching for
doctrines the Commandments of men
and this particular issue is going to be
a focal issue in the last days indeed
the mock of the Beast hinges on a
willingness to obey God or willingness
to obey man
when you find era run from it amen next
please Pastor here's an interesting
question during the flood the Bible says
everything was destroyed well what about
the water dwelling animals how were they
destroyed or were they didn't quite say
that it said everything on dry land
in whom was the Breath of Life died
now wheels and fish like that sharks
don't live on dry land they live in the
ocean and you know what I've said this
about four times already we talked about
dinosaurs these huge creatures that
would be a menace to humanity after the
the declension of man's life span and
stature we'll show you a bit of that
tonight these animals would have been
too hard to cope with God allowed them
to perish in the flood but there is a
beast in the sea that has been referred
to as the Leviathan The Whale the sea
monster the gray whale the blue whale
the blue whale that thing can be up to
60 feet long and weigh tons and tons and
tons
he did not pass away with the Dinosaurs
because he lives in water therefore the
flood did not destroy him next please
Pastor I was baptized in the remnant
church at an early age don't get me
wrong I know
what I was doing
but I am now in my later age I'm
learning more truth is it necessary to
be baptized again in the same Remnant
church I think I ought to say this first
of all you need to talk to your pastor
if you remember the church talk to your
pastor but I need to say this about
baptism baptism into the Lord's Remnant
church is the door to the church
and it does not disallow your religious
experience before it took place
on the other hand if you have been
baptized please don't give the
impression to younger people that they
will have to do it again sometimes young
people can have a rich and valid
experience the first time with the Lord
and simply continue to grow and develop
from there next please
Pastor for children under the age of
making their own decision and the
parents are separate in their decision
but one parent is a Christian what are
the scriptures what did the scripture
say for the children's salvation the
scriptures say train up a child in the
way he should go and whichever one is
the Christian has that responsibility do
the best you can there might be
influences in the home with the
unchristian partner I don't know who you
are so I'm simply trying to answer
generally there might be influences in
the home through an unchristian partner
that will make it difficult for you to
train your children you do your best and
Jesus will stand by you and he said my
grace is sufficient for thee he'll help
you next please
Pastor Brook someone wants to know is it
wrong to have weddings or funerals on
the Sabbath were there a lot of things
that are not wrong they just might not
be best a wedding is actually a sacred
ceremony the problem is not so much with
a wedding but with the expectations and
the festivities that usually attend the
winning you want your affection centered
on Christ not on each other and so my
best wisdom would be plan apart from
Sabbath if possible next please
Pastor do we pay tithe on gifts and if
so to what extent for example if someone
were to give you a car for example do
you estimate the price of that car and
pay accordingly that's what I do
anybody want to give me a hundred
dollars I'll take it and then I'll pay
ten dollars a Time next month our last
question for tonight how can we possibly
overcome the devil when he has so much
power oh that's true he has power but
let me tell you he's Mighty but God is
Almighty and he does not leave us alone
to battle against the devil would
somebody say Amen out there in James
chapter 4 and verse 7 the bible says
resist the devil and he'll flee from you
how do you resist him you sure don't
resist him by toying around with him
playing games with him one of the best
things you'll ever learn to do is once
you know God's will decide right then
I'm going to do this
and mean it and the quicker you stop
slipping and sliding the quicker the
devil will back off
amen resist the devil and he will flee
from you in Philippians chapter 4 and
verse 13 Paul said I can do all things
how many
through Christ which strength me and
then in Ephesians chapter 6 he said put
on the whole armor of God that you might
be able to resist the fiery dots of the
enemy
but on the whole armor and he mentions
The Shield of faith The Shield of Faith
they tell me the Roman soldiers had a
long shield and they could bump it
against the ground and just bend their
knees a little and it protected them
from head to foot
when you've got a shield of Faith like
that it protects you from head to toe
would you say Amen devil can throw all
the dots he wants to but you are hidden
behind the shield of the faith and every
now and then you take the sword of the
spirit which is the word of God and you
stick him
I want to tell you you can overcome oh
yes you can
don't allow excuses God wouldn't tell
you to do it if he didn't give you the
power to do it
are the seven last plagues in Christ's
Second Coming the only events left to be
fulfilled in Prophecy someone has said
that 95 percent of all prophecy is now
history that's precious little left it
is referred to as acute eschatological
prophecy those things that happened just
before the coming of Our Lord now there
are a few other things we look for
Matthew 24 14 says this Gospel of the
Kingdom shall be preached in all the
world for a witness to All Nations and
then shall the income that is one of the
things we look forward to and then
another according to Revelation 13 is
when an image to the Beast is formed
here and men are forced their
consciences are forced let me tell you
Newsweek magazine Time Magazine and USA
Today are already talking about morality
by force we are very close to the final
things being fulfilled
Pastor Brooks is it true that the
Catholic Church says that Protestants
pay homage to them in spite of
themselves as it relates to Sunday
observance that is a statement I have it
on the screen I just enjoyed to you the
the Roman Church you see they believe
the things that they teach Protestants
are totally without an excuse
and they try to make up excuses they say
we keep the first day of the week in
honor of the Resurrection no they don't
they keep it because the Catholic Church
made Sunday a holiday by majority vote
at the Council of laodicea and the 4th
Century A.D and if they were honest
about it they would admit such next
place
Pastor even though there is no
distinction of color or race and
teaching in the teaching of Jesus is it
not true that Jesus was a black man why
is this truth not taught as a matter of
Truth well the the first part of the
question says isn't it true and then it
says why isn't this truth taught
the presumption is that it is and the
truth is it is not true Jesus was not
black now I've said this uh several
times he was not Spanish
Jesus was not white
Jesus was of Jewish kin
it is not necessary that he be black to
be my savior it is necessary that he be
the Son of God and he was
and so
please don't deceive oneself by saying
why isn't this true thought it is not
the truth he was Jewish and someone said
that they in those days were generally
Olive skinned they lived under a a
warmer son sort of like Phoenix you see
and Christ is called in scripture the
desire of all Nations
I don't care how you imagine him but by
all means know that he was God's son he
still is next please Pastor is there
anything wrong and going to Worship the
Lord on Sunday provided that you keep
the Sabbath holy are you still in danger
of getting the mark of the beast already
discussed this the Bible says in Acts 5
29 now you notice you got a scripture
for these things why don't you believe
the Bible
the Bible says we ought to obey God
rather than man would you say Amen
second Corinthians 6 14 says be not
unequally yoked together with
unbelievers God is calling for
separation his people will be separated
sooner or later now he has Saints in
every communion but those who find truth
do not need in fact why would you want
to go back to doing what God expressly
forbids he said in vain do they worship
me teaching for doctrines the
Commandments of men that's Matthew 15
and verse 9. ladies and gentlemen once
you know never look back next please
Pastor please explain to us Matthew 5 48
therefore you shall be perfect just as
your father in Heaven is perfect a
relative term naturally you can't be
like God perfect in your sphere even as
God is in his and by the way Perfection
is when one accepts Christ as his Savior
and is willing to do whatever Christ
requires of him that man is judged
perfect would you say Amen out there the
Bible says job was perfect the Bible
says Noah was perfect these men were not
without fault it was simply they were
covered by the righteousness of the Lord
Jesus Christ and were willing to do
whatever he said
perfect in your sphere as Christ or God
is in his
can I destroy God's Temple if I eat too
much or too often because of health
problems my doctor says I need to eat
between meals well there are many
relatives here first of all it depends
on how much you eat some people are
gutting us they eat too much and are
destroying their health now I like to
eat I always have it's the only Vice I
have left
and you have to resist the temptation to
overdo it but if your doctor told you a
little bit between meals do it he ought
to know what he's doing I hope next one
why do I get so many people trying to
tell me not to obey God well that's a
mystery to me and then again it's not
you see we're not alone down here the
devil and myriads of
super-powered Angels were cast out of
heaven and the Bible says in Matthew
Revelation Revelation 12 and verse 9 he
was cast out into the Earth and his
angels were cast out with him the devil
is here and his angels are here and he
uses individuals who resist obedience to
God's word if you understand that would
you say Amen let me tell you something I
almost can guarantee it if you went down
into Phoenix wherever people hang out
and you shouted almost to the top of
your lungs I'm going to get drunk
tonight
I can almost guarantee you people will
laugh and they will applaud you and some
will want to know where you're going to
get it so they can join you
but very few people will tell you that's
not good you shouldn't do that
folk are doing the most degrading things
and yet nobody says don't do it but the
minute you find God's truth and begin to
obey him you got a thousand advisors
they are sent by the devil
to discourage you I told you you can't
be a lily living coward and be a
Christian you got to first know the
truth now don't just take my word for it
I could fool you
I'm like all the rest if I tell you and
it's not in here I don't believe it now
is that clear
but once you study God's word and know
it's true you got to have a mind all by
yourself and you've got to say by the
grace of God I'm going to obey God and
the certain man to whom Angels rally
and the devil can't force you to do
anything
that you shouldn't do someone who says
first of all I thank God for allowing me
to hear the truth I am happy and in awe
but it also frightens me is that normal
oh don't let it frighten you but to be
expectant and to be happy and to be
excited I think that's normal find God's
truth is never sent to embarrass you
it's never sent to offend you there are
people offended by it but that's not why
it's sent it is sent to Enlighten us it
is sent through the love of God it is
said that we might know what God expects
of us
and above all that we might get to know
Jesus whom to know is life eternal
someone wants to know is shaving an
adornment can it be done by Christian
women example legs and eyebrows uh
I'm so glad to tell you the Bible
doesn't make everything wrong
I I you know somebody wrote me a
question the other night want to know is
it a sin to wear a wig
that all depends
wigs have become I understand very
convenient for some ladies who haven't
had a chance to go and get their hair
all done and they can put on a wig and
run to the store and nobody knows the
difference
some of these wigs have been a blessing
but on the other hand let us avoid
artificiality amen I don't think a
Christian needs a green wig
and some of us are not naturally blind
natural but it's not wrong to shave you
see we are not as God originally made us
we have been uglified by sin and it
doesn't hurt to do some things to make
you I'm not trying to be funny it
doesn't hurt to make yourself attractive
just try to avoid artificiality for the
Bible condemns that
Pastor someone wants to know did you
study Theology and if so what is it what
does it mean and do Jewish people have
the same concordance that we have two
words theocynology they mean a study of
God a study of God yes we study Theology
and the Jewish people are the number one
in in religious education and my church
is number two that might Amaze you but
it is next place Pastor Brooks does the
Bible say anything about an older woman
and a younger man or vice versa no the
Bible tells us to be wise and the Bible
tells us to pray and in all thy ways
acknowledge Him and He will direct your
path every Christian has the right to
talk to God about his personal affairs
and expect God to guide him would you
say Amen now if you want to ignore that
you can get into real trouble I was at a
place once an 81 year old man wanted to
marry a 16 year old girl and he went
around tried to get preachers to do it
and they wouldn't so I guess he thought
he could come to me I said absolutely
positively not
now it doesn't mean you have to be
exactly the same age
but it does mean you ought to be as
compatible as possible when you get
married you need everything going for
you you can get actually
Dr Brooks here's someone that wants to
know about a unicorn
the Bible mentions the unicorn in three
different references three different
books that is three different books
mentioned the unicorn in Psalm Psalm 22
and verse 21 the Bible mentions the
Unicorn now remember our Bible was
translated from the Hebrew and Aramaic
in the Old Testament Greek in the new
into English and what they tried to do
was match as perfectly as possible the
meaning of the original text when you
look into the Hebrew it generally refers
to the wild ox and in some cases the
rhinoceros but if you read Psalm 22
you'll notice this unicorn has horns not
one horn and sin of the Void horns next
please
someone wants to know if the Bible says
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceedeth out of the
mouth of God does that mean that you
will die if you just eat bread or what
does it mean please explain doesn't
refer to the eating of bread at all
there was an occasion where people were
all concerned about the appetites and
Jesus said man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word how many words
if you read the Ten Commandments in
Exodus 20 you read these words and God
spake all how many all these words say
God didn't give nine Commandments he
gave ten and Jesus said man shall live
by every word how many that proceedeth
out of the mouth of God he's talking
about something spiritual more than
something physical and this by the way
is the bread of life next please someone
wants to know how come women ordained
can preach the gospel when it doesn't
say so in the Bible look at Revelation
chapter 22 verse 18. I'm acquainted with
that text it has nothing to do with this
question it says if any man adds to or
takes away from the writings of God that
man will bear the disapproval and curse
of God
but if women are called to preach all I
say is
it there's nothing here that precludes
that I'm trying to tell you it might not
match your taste but there is no Divine
prohibition next please
Pastor Brooks I heard you answer the
question regarding dinosaurs it caused
me to wonder why science has not yet
found the bones belonging to any giant
man could it be that Modern Man in order
to find these bones would negate coming
to God and negate his faith well in the
first place a Christian must live by
faith not by what is proved by science
would you say Amen out there now I don't
understand all of the types of things
you ask I I maybe because man even
though he was a giant man was not nearly
as big as a dinosaur and serious
deterioration has taken place in
dinosaur bones maybe the smaller bones
of man comparatively have completely
returned to dust the Bible says that's
what would happen to him but the
dinosaur has a bone as big as is my body
almost and they are so large and they
have been encased in rock and and they
have been preserved miraculously next
please
someone wants to know if it's painful to
die they go on to say I pray that I die
in my sleep or at church hearing the
word of God
well don't worry about that beloved you
leave that in the hands of the Lord
one thing he said is I'll never leave
you nor forsake you and if he's with you
whatever it is his grace is sufficient
would you say amen I really don't worry
about that very much what I'm concerned
about is that I'll die on the Lord's
Side now I've seen people die on both
sides and just watching it has made me
feel that when I die I want to die easy
expert one of our friends wants to know
I wear makeup in moderation sometimes to
cover up my blemishes my ears are
pierced and I wear small earrings that
were given to me as a gift I also wear a
mother's ring what does the Bible say
about makeup and jewelry I've already
preached it to you the other night read
Isaiah chapter 3 start with verse 16.
and read it prayerfully
and and when a person suggests I won't
do a big saying I'll just do a little
one
after you know about it becomes a sin if
you say I won't do a big one I'll do a
little one that's really a an insult to
God a Christian is ready to do
everything God says amen now there are
things that you do to help yourself I
don't think the Bible forbids that but
I've talked about artificiality and
Superfluous adornings and the Methodist
Church and other churches used to teach
this as strongly as we do they just let
it go we haven't let it go next please
pastor this person says I'm a Jewish
Christian how do we know when the
Sabbath is because man made the calendar
man didn't make the days God gave them
God numbered them and God gave a Sabbath
God would never require you to do
something you couldn't find out or
figure out
remember now God is intelligent and
Truth is logical and reasonable and in
Ecclesiastes 3 14-15 the Bible says I
know that whatsoever God do it it shall
be forever nothing can be put to it nor
anything taken from it and God doeth it
that men should fear before him that
which hath men is now and that which is
to be has already been and God requireth
that which is past not only that but
during the time that Israel was in the
wilderness God performed Miracles every
week and every Sabbath thousands of
Miracles occurred during that 40-year
Soldier every day except Sabbath Manna
came down
and on the side of none came down
and if he gathered enough on Tuesday the
last all day Wednesday because you were
lazy the Bible says it stank and worms
got in it but on Friday when you
gathered enough for Sabbath it stayed
fresh all these are Miracles and God
re-established the the rhythm of the
weekly cycle no no no there's no problem
except to decide to obey God experts our
final question for tonight Dr Brooks you
said a Christian woman should dress
modestly so not to entice or seduce what
then is the cause of elderly ladies
being raped when they don't entice or
seduce it has nothing to do with God's
rule of modesty and people who rate
generally are involved in a kind of of
degeneracy a kind of violence against
women and the dress has nothing to do
with that that's a different discussion
altogether but listen when it comes to
understanding God we have to know him
for ourselves
we have to know his word for ourselves
you might not know everything but line
up with that which you know and the
Bible says if any man will do his will
he shall know of the doctrine when you
do what you know he'll give you more to
do why should he show you other things
when you're not doing what you know so
it boils down to a personal decision
what saith the Lord when you find out do
it and you don't have to be a fanatic I
don't even like fanatics
they make the truth unattractive isn't
that right now I'm an evangelist I have
to tell you the truth you know what if I
didn't tell you the truth I'd be lost
so I got no choice I'm not trying to be
tough
I have to do it and when you find it out
just be calm it's not an excitable thing
you don't have to stand on your head
just because and God will lead you you
have a relationship with him you love
him and you do what he says because you
do